ich bin als oberleutnant der
arbeitsjahre für truppe hier in
korneuburg beim kommando bcr
kompaniekommandant arbeitet er war
bedeutete die abwehr von atomaren
biologischen und chemischen gefahren zum
schutz der bevölkerung und natürlich
eigenen truppe die aufgaben des company
kommen sind sehr vielfältig also zu den
aufgaben in frieden zurück natürlich
auch einiges administratives man kann
sie das ungefähr so vorstellen minister
der chef einer firma mit immer permanent
zwischen 60 und 140 mitarbeitern
dekontamination bedeutet ein strahlen
immer fallen oder and solchen im bva
oder entgiften im cv die dekontamination
wird mit dem system mammut durchgeführt
[Musik]
ich habe die abkommen hat dann kann man
da habe ich gehabt und er ist nun kommt
meine aufgabe system haben sie oft
einzuführen
daran hängt bei der bürger haben
da wird die rücknahme versteht man in
weniger gefährliche stoffe hat dass man
die verhältnisse unserer partner zu
werden
[Musik]
ich bin wachsam retter und bezog dort
eingeteilt dass kommandant eines
brunches und zuständig für ein fahrzeug
und die dazugehörige mannschaft und wir
müssen zuerst den brand löschen damit
mit dem retten von verletzten personen
begonnen werden kann
[Musik]
das besondere an uns ist dass wir die
beamten in einer normalen gebiet sondern
auch in einem verstreut verläuft oder
verdichteten gebieten zur
brandbekämpfung in einem verstrahlten
gebiet benutzen wir unseren gramm stoff
präsidenten bzw
[Musik]
[Applaus]